nous avons aujourd'hui un nouveau
monsieur niet à la tête de l'État
monsieur niet ni dissolution ni
remaniement ni référendum
peut considérer que Monsieur Macron
aujourd'hui est en manque d'idées je ne
sais pas ce qu'il annoncera demain à 13h
d'ailleurs le choix de 13h est assez
significatif puisque
tout le monde ne sera pas présent enfin
les salariés peut-être seront au travail
n'écoutons pas le président de la
République mais peu importe que vous que
va-t-il nous annoncer un nouveau grand
débat
une nouvelle convention nationale
citoyenne un nouveau Conseil national de
la refondation
rien
mais manifestement le premier République
est aveugle il est sourd mais
manifestement il ne sera plus muet à
partir de 13 heures demain
à partir de là mesdames et messieurs et
après nous rentrons dans le détail des
procédures les groupes de gauche ici
présents ont décidé de porter
naturellement 60 députés et plus 60
sénateurs et plus de recours devant le
Conseil constitutionnel puisque nous
avons beaucoup de reproches à faire au
fond et à la forme peut-être plus
d'ailleurs au Sénat sur la forme parce
que nous avons été jusqu'au bout de
l'examen de ce texte et beaucoup de
problèmes de procédures ont été repérés
au Sénat nous pourrons en train d'être
dans le détail si vous le souhaitez mais
à côté de cette démarche assez classique
du recours nous allons lancer nous avons
lancé avec plus de 250 parlementaires
députés sénateurs sénateurs députés la
procédure du référendum partagé qui vous
le savez n'est pas ne nous est pas
inconnue nous l'avons déjà testé avec un
succès politique même si tu ne sais pas
un succès juridique dans le récemment de
la privatisation d'ADP qui n'a pas pu
aller jusqu'au bout parce que nous avons
porté devant les Français cette décision
injuste et aujourd'hui économiquement
qui aurait été catastrophique avec la
crise de la covid de privatiser les
aéroports de Paris et bien nous
relançons cette démarche avec un
objectif qui est le dire au président de
la République vous qui n'entendez rien
vous qui ne voyiez rien vous qui ne
ressentez rien par rapport à la
souffrance des Français et bien monsieur
le Président de la République nous
voulons que les Français puissent
s'exprimer au travers de 4 millions 800
000 signatures que nous irons chercher
si bien sûr le Conseil constitutionnel
valide notre démarche qui est maintenant
sur son bureau et nous voulons que les
Français puissent dire ce qu'il pense de
cette réforme que nous avons toujours
considéré comme très impopulaire injuste
et
inutile donc cette ces deux démarches
complémentaires et j'en resterai là
montre que nous allons nous attaquer
mesdames et messieurs
au bunker des certitudes dans lequel vit
le président de la République ce bunker
de la certitude et des certitudes et
finalement la marque de fabrique d'un
président qui ne doute pas
il ne doute jamais de ce qu'il est et de
ses choix et bien nous allons essayer de
montrer que les Français non seulement
doutent des choix inopportuns du
président de la République mais qu'en
plus ils vont combattre ces choix que
nous avons porté en opposition tant à
l'Assemblée cosena merci encore à nos
collègues députés d'avoir permis un
sénateur mais il y aura d'autres
sénateurs et sénatrices qui vont
s'exprimer d'avoir ouvert cette
conférence de presse
[Musique]